and I agree I feel after reading this
paper you know everybody's sort of
pushing out you need to test test and
trace trace right and it seems like
we're beyond the point potentially
beyond the point of tracing at this
point but is is that is that like um did
Newt so we're thinking about a place
like New Zealand and I don't know if
this is outside of the realm of this
paper where where they are they're
saying that they're coalbed free right
and is it because they did these types
of efforts like in the bit from the very
beginning um if you know um I'm not sure
I think it is partially because they had
stricter lockdown measures and they made
sure people were wearing masks and they
actually shut everything down because
what happened with us is we didn't
actually shut down our testing capacity
is very limited and part of how contact
tracing work because you need to be able
to test people to say this person that's
coded so that you can actually I think
sorry go ahead
oh no problem I just I read an
interesting article about contact
tracing efforts that are currently
ongoing in Utah was it Utah Domini
I think so yeah and I think it's just
sort of interesting to think about how
in the u.s. I think the u.s. is very
heterogeneous right we have a lot of
different states with different
approaches and I think there are still
places in the US where the numbers are
still relatively low and so I think you
know I think that's not to say that
contact tracing may not have any utility
in in certain places I think especially
because you know as we've learned more
about the disease like it seems like are
not is not three point five it's a bit
lower and you know I think I think some
of the scenarios we mapped out here were
a little bit extreme
but yeah I think it's sort of all it
really seems like it's been varying a
lot like country to country in place to
place about what techniques are really
really feasible in different situations
right great so I was curious my husband
who also does math models but within
cancer has to defend his work I think a
lot to biologists and people who don't
necessarily understand his work but is
there a way to kind of help people
understand where these kinds of
mathematical models fit within
understanding disease kind of
particularly these kinds of infectious
diseases and how you then compare
afterwards to say yes this was a
legitimate model for this disease
dominant you wanna start with the Sun
and I can chime in sure so the issue
with models like all of your teachers
that teach you how to model discusses
that all models are wrong because all
models are an oversimplification it's
hard to know I think how accurate a
model is if you're not actually
implementing all the parameters like for
this model for instance like this was
based on information that turned out not
to be true at least in the u.s. a lot of
all my research and readings been on
stuff that's happening in the u.s.
because this was assuming that we would
have like a smaller population and
there'd be one or two three four like a
limited number of people who come in
with the virus and in the u.s. at least
it seems like the number was much much
higher so I think that it's less
about seeing whether or not the model is
a good model and tuning the parameters
of the model in order to better match
reality or putting in other pieces like
you know maybe this person goes into
isolation but they occasionally come out
of their house and like how do you model
that now they have a higher infectivity
when they leave and you have to account
for that but I think it's about figuring
out what to account for and it really
depends a lot on the data that you're
gathering because that is what informs
the creation of your model in the first
place I'm I'll say I'd like not an
expert on pandemic modeling I'm a bio
physicist so I you know everything with
a grain of salt get actual information
from experts but as someone who spills a
bunch of computational models it really
really depends on the data that you get
and the effectiveness you have of
gathering the data I think also I think
just as a as an individual looking at
models is a is a helpful practice to
think it forces you to think really
specifically about what are the
different factors that that could have
an effect since you have to explicitly
list them out and so even just like as a
person reading this paper you know
sometimes you come across factors that
you hadn't thought of yourself or you
know people make an assumption and you
say oh that assumption isn't I don't
think that's a good assumption and it
forces you to think about more about why
that's the case I think doing this work
early at the start of the pandemic can
be helpful because you're sort of
exploring a range of possibilities and
then once you've laid the groundwork as
you get more accurate information you
can feed that into these existing models
so hopefully get slightly slightly more
informed more informed not predictions
because it's not really predicting
exactly what's going to happen but
just more informed yeah more important
models more informed pictures of what
might be possible and I think also
really looking at like the role of
different variables compared to each
other I think one thing that happens
when people run models like this is that
they'll see you know they'll test the
effect of especially when you can vary
to two different parameters at once you
might see that okay like I can changing
parameter a has a much bigger effect
than changing parameter B even if on
their own they each have an effect there
might be a much bigger effect
contribution from one than the other and
that can help you then sort of tease
apart you know if if approach one seems
to have a much more impact much greater
impact then approach to then maybe it's
worth fuelling our resources into
approach one rather than worrying about
approach - yeah and just for reference
so most of my husband David's work is
actually talking to biologists and
getting the parameter since you were
just talking about yeah and it seems
like those parameters it's like you only
know what you know right and so there's
always something that you don't know
that you're potentially missing and so I
imagine it's complicated and hard and
but I also feel like there's so much
value and beauty and and Joanne through
a comment in about the beauty of a model
that you can plug in the values based on
you information right and so um yeah i
i'm i'm grateful for modeling even
though i think you know you're probably
right in saying Deveny and everybody who
teaches modeling you know all models are
wrong but you know it's the best we have
at this point in time so we have a
question from Stephanie
that says did the paper discuss anything
about how long an interaction between
people had to be worth you know had to
take place in order should be worth
tracing like if somebody was at the
grocery store like a cat you know and
checked out with a cashier
two friends catching up for 15 minutes
like is there a difference or in in like
how we're thinking about that for
contact tracing so I think in practice
definitely in this paper no correct me
if I'm wrong Devon II but I think they
modeled every contact as identical yeah
yeah but I know in practice that's
definitely something that people are
talking a lot about you know both in
terms of like how likely is it that the
disease is spreading in these momentary
interactions and also along the axis of
how feasible is it for us to be able to
trace this person because if you're
relying on people like a left to
interact agenda that's a problem if
they're interacting with people in
passing at the grocery store other
people other countries have gotten
around that like in South Korea by using
digital tracking and accessing people's
you know GPS signals and and credit card
information like the government doing
this to be able to see where people were
going in relation to each other clearly
that's not something that's like
politically feasible in the u.s. that
people wouldn't be comfortable with so I
think that sort of harkens back to our
earlier point that I think different
different you need different approaches
in different locations
it's not a one-size-fits-all situation
yeah it feels like there could be a very
slippery slope if we give access to our
personal data to government people it
seems like I don't know I'm not sure
it's worth the risk might that's my
personal opinion
yeah at least at this point in time yeah
I think the great thing though is that
once you have a model like this that
that is the type of question that you
could then build on this model to
incorporate so you know what we
presented today is these are the
assumptions and the setup that these
researchers decided to go with but this
isn't the only way that they could have
chosen to do this and you know if you if
you're coding savvy and downloaded the
the simulation you could go and you know
it probably would be kind of difficult
but you could go and add on some of
these components to the existing
simulation to see what effect they have
yeah you could model things like you
know if you have weak contact the
percent chance that you're gonna pass on
the disease it's like you know have
recorded or something like that or you
have a strong contact it could be the go
way up and that's sort of how you could
model that but in this model they did
not take that into account but it's a
sort of a baseline for building more
complex models in the future yeah and in
this model they do actually take into
account for certain variables the fact
that interact enter but these are not
the same for every person so we didn't
describe this in detail but for example
for the onset to isolation delay they
weren't just plugging in 3 days or 8
days for every person they actually had
like a distribution that they sampled
from that was centered at 3 days for the
short delay and centered at eight days
for the long delay but you could still
get like seven day delay 10-day delay
three-day delay for different
interactions in the simulation so there
is a little bit more complexity that you
can build in okay so Susan wants to know
is the contact tracing dependent on the
reporting of the infected individual I
think it depends on like Anna was saying
the country you're in um so here I
believe it would be because I don't
think you can get information like that
like you can't get someone's credit card
data to figure out like what grocery
stores they've been to you so you'd have
to say you know who are who've you been
in contact with and like do you have
their phone number just like tech
companies like sorry I'm sorry I know
before us for your for your stopping um
but aren't there like did an apple like
have a thing where if somebody somebody
can input themselves as positive and if
they've come into proximity of other
iPhone users that there would be some
alert
Wow so I don't know like I was reading
about this recently you know I'm not a
hundred percent my understanding of
what's happened is that Apple and Google
actually teamed up and they've built an
API which is sort of like a data
interface that you use via the internet
and so they created this API that's
supposed to be helpful in coordinating
that type of information but they have
not built any sort of unified app to do
this and so they released such as states
and states individually then have the
ability for the responsibility to
develop their own apps using this API to
do the tracing but I think as someone
mentioned in the comments I think there
has been pushed back on this and there
are a number of states who have
attempted to try and do this but I think
it has an action I don't know if it's
actually been rolled out anywhere I
think there have been some issues it
feels can actually accomplish for
example New York State has like you know
a whole tech angle or office that could
build things like this without you know
at least on top of the work that they
already have seems it's an interesting
idea and I'm not familiar with how that
that risks privacy but it feels like we
have so much technology and so many tech
giants that like I just I wish that we
were doing more to incorporate that into
everything yeah I think Taiwan I don't
remember the details but I believe that
Taiwan developed some sort of like app
or some sort of system that wasn't even
I think it was more of like a there's
sort of a history I think of the
Taiwanese government kind of almost
collaborating with different like hacker
individuals within the the community and
so I think this was another partnership
kind of similar to that where it maybe
wasn't as like government-led
necessarily but it was sort of this
collaboration where they put out this
call and got people to work on this
together
I think this there is
a really important balance between you
know people's privacy concerns you know
using things like Apple and Google
versus handing it over to the government
I don't necessarily feel comfortable
with either personally but the UK
decided that they I think Apple and
Google offered to make its Apple they
created it and then they said well we
don't really want to use that we want to
have our own accept then of course they
weren't taking advantage of like the
technological advances that they have
and there were the chances that because
it wasn't a sanctioned app for these
these particular devices that it wasn't
going to be able to keep up like it
wasn't going to ping as often so yeah
it's amiss all right let's take a
question question from Maggie well I'm
gonna give a little shout out to hello
Maggie
is there any data about the average time
it takes for someone to no longer be
contagious or recover from coab at 19
and if so has there been any models that
take into account the average amount of
time spent in isolation so yes yes we do
now I just looked up an actual number
from the World Health Organization so
they found out that people with mild
disease recovery time is about two weeks
which is why like my lab had someone
come in from overseas like right at the
very beginning of the pandemic and he
had to spend two weeks in total
quarantine so the recovery time is about
two weeks and incubation time is shorter
than that and then people obviously who
get more sick it's gonna be longer
generally they recover within three to
six weeks so this is very simple to take
into account in your model what's the
actual question many models that take
into account the average amount of time
spent in isolation yeah so I think the
standard isolation period is two weeks
I've seen several people in a new lab so
a lot of people are coming in moving
around so we've had a bunch of people
have to be in isolation I think Anna
Anna and I had a friend who moved to
Anna's lab who came in from China
and she had to spend two weeks in
quarantine before she started working so
I think that's probably like their time
for isolation because that seems like
that's the standard time what's not
enforced or is an enforcer as it's sort
of like at the honor system
I think it's honor system and I think
people well I I'm pretty sure the people
I know who've been had to be under
quarantine or has been pretty careful
because a lot of them are working in
hospitals cuz yeah a really interesting
little factoid that that's tangentially
related that I learned is that you know
initially they I remember at the start
of the Pend I think there was some talk
about the people who were in isolation
using repeat viral testing so the PCR
test to see if you have virus and you
using like negative they were trying to
use negative readings on that as a
criteria for letting someone out of
isolation but what we've learned since
then is that the virus actually like
particles of the virus stay in your
system for a very long time much longer
than the period through which you're
actually infectious so you can't use the
PCR test really to to determine when
someone is no longer infectious because
they can keep showing up positive on
that test for up to 12 weeks after they
had symptoms but they are not they are
certainly no longer infectious at that
point the actual infectious period is
much shorter so how do you I mean do you
have to just lean on antibody levels or
how do you you know how do you determine
make that determination if yeah so yeah
so the the current approach at least
that I'm familiar with and that I
believe they're using in the hospitals
here in New York or at Mount Sinai are
ten days from symptom onset in addition
to being three days
without any fever or fever reducing
medications and the complete alleviation
of all symptoms okay so it's more a
symptom symptom and time-based metrics
interesting tying back to the talks that
our colleague dr. Delos Pollard gave
recently on diabetes is their way to
include diabetes incidents for example
in this type of model I believe so are
we looking at how much this person is
going to suffer from the disease when
they get it I think maybe severity I
mean our diabetic patients at higher
risk for more adverse yeah they're in
one of the high-risk groups yeah so this
I think it's more modeling spread rather
than actual severity and the one
parameter I would think that would
affect the model based on how severe
your symptoms are gonna be is the amount
of time that you had the virus that
might affect like how long you need to
be in isolation but that's not I don't
think that's gonna really affect the
model and I you can correct me yeah I
think you're right in saying that this
model is really just modeling modeling
spread it's not really looking at like
what's happening what's happening to the
people who get sick so but there are
other models certainly that you could
incorporate those sorts of factors into
I think the the SI r model that was
presented on May 20th
that one looks at you know people being
infected and then also some proportion
of people being either recovering or
dying and so I imagine that you could
elaborate on that model and incorporate
in variables like the proportion of the
population that is diabetic and looking
at the effect on that sub population
within a model like that I guess there
is
one small subset of people who with
regards to smokers I don't know if other
people read this that smokers
potentially were less likely to get the
infection but if they did get it they're
more likely to have very adverse effects
kind of symptoms that's weird
I wonder why that is yeah the thing is
we don't want to encourage people to
smoke but yeah it feels like that that
could be a parameter that thing could
potentially plug into if they're less
likely to be infected and they're less
likely to spread it yeah and that's a
primary that definitely I could see
would vary a lot country to country and
so you know if you're you can take that
into account the differences in
populations between different locations
and that might affect the sorts of
control approaches that that you might
want to take I think with regard to some
of these different these different
health considerations I was reading a
little bit about how you know I think
initially everyone was really concerned
about people with existing respiratory
issues people with asthma but from what
I've read it seems like it's turned out
to be less those people are not
necessarily as much of a concern or at
least asthmatic people aren't and that
actually it's really people with
pre-existing like heart disease and
heart conditions because actually the
virus really there's been a lot of
clotting involved and a lot of damage to
the endothelial lining I believe I
really it's the cardiovascular system
that really takes a hit in a lot of ways
so it's a slightly different population
of people we're starting to learn are at
risk compared to what we initially
thought yeah it's just it's a such a it
seems like such a complicated biology
and you know to be in it real-time while
also trying to keep our people safe is a
it's no small feat I think